hello my name is Anton Antonov I am a
co-founder of a company ascended data in
which I act as a senior applied
mathematician my talk is about
exemplifying cultural differences
between machine learning and statistics
the abstract which I have published when
i submitted this talk like 3-4 months
ago it's not very actual but you know I
have made some updates before discussing
we hope discussing what I'm going to
present I would like to to say that I do
have some background bands bus my
background is in a large-scale air
pollution simulations I did study
general algebra before God in
large-scale air pollution simulations
these are a lot of scientific
subcultures solving pgs or this great
generation computational fluid dynamics
large-scale linear algebra also lots of
programming I do like operations
research I have worked I own
optimization problems for for the
industry and so when it comes to
statistics for whatever reasons I have
been always kind of suspicious of
statistics institutions very often I
don't see why the statistical language
should be used we ultimately we use
linear algebra and an optimization so
this is not necessarily a good attitude
I just think it's a valid one I can show
you what with this attitude i have
actually resolved lots of problems which
actually is the decisions at least the
ones i have met have not been able to do
for for whatever reasons um I in the
companies I work for with lots of data
scientists and engineers I have been
playing the statistician role so but
this is not because I want to adjust
sometimes really I mean we need to we
need to utilize statistics I do think
what such ditions the successful
suspicions are more likely to be the
so-called timid professionals you can
see this book which is referenced there
it's called disciplined minds and the
successful machine learning
practitioners are more likely to be
maverick feel free to disagree with
everything i said so far
but you know to some extent I'm
exaggerating a little bit in order to
make a point this is not about
statistics this talk it's not about
statistics and data science data science
is much more general it's a little bit
it's the overlap between machine
learning and statistics and in this
particular case in this particular scope
of the talk it's more about predictions
and recommendations and in general we
can see data science and machine
learning as part of statistics I mean if
you deal with data you doing statistics
where we have seen this well inspector
element and finite element methods you
kind of do the same thing you do in
statistics so you you come up with a
model you solve some optimization
problem which comes with whatever
Hilbert spaces you have been utilizing
then you verify the model you better
open this models of the piggies a linear
and you have some basis functions and so
forth so similarly I mean this is
something you doing in statistics when
you do say linear regression use the
gauss-markov Markov theorem which
guarantees you what you'll get unbiased
estimate and so forth so basically
you're solving calm optimization problem
which which then you need to verify in
whatever ways in or visit valid vin
someone knowledge in music but i don't
know no don't go for it so when when it
comes to the difference between such
decisions and machine learning
practitioners i would like to point the
parrot along which is also known as the
8020 rules to tween 8020 rule like
twenty percent of the sessions
contribute age eighty percent make
eighty percent of the contributions now
as a spec watch in machine learning it's
like fifteen percent of the machine
gunners contribute you know ninety five
percent of of the contributions in
machine learning but whatever i'm
basically this talk is more about the
long tail people in this in this field
and you know a reference for the rest of
us so i'm going to move to
to this to our this free machine
learning protagonists the simple nuclear
physicist is a guy who actually very
often is responsible for lots of data
and they they just cannot throw it away
these lots of data has been produced
with say millions of dollars of
investments so in general physicists can
become very good data scientist gela
protagonist is the operation the common
operations research analyst who might be
working in say cruise line however in
this particular case he is going to be
working in a riverboat casino and the
standard machine learning engineer which
is kind of me basics basically called
data scientist very often so the major
geological differences and
methodological differences where we
stood here and one of the things which I
you know it's kind of the lessons you
know to be taught from doing machine
learning when compared to statistics is
what there's a multiplicity of good
models and my first example more
detailed example is going to be showing
that also where they very often it's
hard to produce simple models which
explained the situation in a sense you
have good prediction you have a
complicated model like fing Suffolk like
neural networks etc so this is why is
there is no Occam's razor and high
dimensionality very often is considered
a curse this is very statistical weight
to treat things in statistics very often
people try to reduce the dimensionality
remove access and dimensions and so
forth this is not what machine gunners
do like if you take something like
support vector machines if anything
you're actually increasing the
dimensions you know you actually
embracing the dimensionality the high
dimensionality I do actually think
machine runners they kind of they all
have simplify things and they same as
the decisions very often they try to see
without looking and none of them the
things they do very often is to do
simulation state of models which is
great of course you know
to be careful mashing up of algorithms
again you know could be good could be
could be also very bad and the standard
application is to do collaborative
filtering it basically you're
outsourcing crowdsourcing intelligence
you again you trying to see without
looking these are not necessarily bad
per se but they're not necessarily good
either so you need to be careful when
you apply them this is the overview of
the examples i'm going to go for a go
through in this talk maybe the detailed
examples it seems i will unable to to go
through all of them in detail but i have
made very detailed presentations outside
in a different web depositors and their
links to it the whole talk has saturated
with links and references if you use
this this notebook these are the
packages which are used in in this in
this notebook to the computations the
first example is the receiving
cooperating characteristic example if
you haven't seen before what raucous is
it's basically this this type of plot in
which web which were looking at the
dependency between the true positives
and false positives now this is the our
standard sorry our simple nuclear
physicist is doing this one of the
reasons I mentioned mesh amusing came
here is because physicists they're very
very accustomed to do on facespace
portraits and investigate stuff in phase
spaces even if they don't know thus this
physicist simple nuclear physicist
doesn't know about the rock a curve and
plot he can actually come up with it
it's common sense it's very easy to
define so what he is doing its here some
data set this particular case the
Titanic data set and he's basically
making a bunch of fun he knows what he
uses some kind of library like same of
America he makes several classified as
you can see disclosed first and he makes
an example of them and disassemble of
quad
farce you know produces this result
which is set out which basically the
classification and symbols basically
when you when you have like six or seven
classifiers you can we can if you put a
record to to this set of classifiers you
can just use simple voting or you can do
some averaging of probabilities and you
don't see see what exactly is you know
which of the levels is being voted so
you can see here but if we change this
threshold with this particular assemble
classifier is being chased with changed
Oh bus with the probabilities mean
basically this threshold which is when
do we accept survived when I change the
threshold I get different performance
you can see what's actually I can get
fairly good performance around here so
it's you know but again this comes from
the example one of the things which we
can do is let me I think this is
evaluated so you can see what with the
single classified this is the classifier
with a support vector machine this one
here I get this blue curve and with the
bootstrapping classifier bootstrapping
can sample I'm getting this red curve
it's like I do have actually quite good
performance with some of July
classifiers again this can be even more
more exaggerated we say let's let's
actually try since this is some I did
actually spend some time to do this
serve as a live demonstration
[Music]
so the bootstrapping here it's basically
resembling the data in some way and you
can see what I have actually taken a
slightly smaller fraction Arvind when
the full data and so here we calculated
the bootstraps and so I mean actually in
this case I didn't get I didn't get
better curve which you know surprises me
but usually I do and again you know if I
if I round and yeah I mean let me change
the the seat random you know I very
likely in all who produce better curve
okay well I'm not so but this again you
know like with the bootstrapping
classify bootstrapping it's exactly
manifesting quarter was we sink earlier
but we can actually produce better
models using using unassembled and there
is no simple explanation for that so one
of the things and what this is if we
know just picture if you look at the
previous one it is actually interesting
to to note why is this actually I was
getting with bootstrapping was getting
better results and all of the reasons
here is what I do actually have outliers
in the data and you can see with this
example here but if I systematically
remove females from the data set like
records corresponding to females I'm
kind of using increasingly smaller
females I'm actually kind of having very
different performance and so here you
can see this is the zero point and if I
have removed like say fifteen fifteen
percent of the females I actually get
somewhat better / somewhat better
performance this is actually I'm going
to move to I'm going to move to the next
example which is done with statistics
this is actually can be explained with
you know using what we're having
outliers in the data this by the way
it's a very simple the whole thing with
a rock statistic it's a very simple very
simple enough if you look at this
article here everything here it's like
pretty high school math it's all ratios
and so forth it's fairly it's fairly
straightforward
there's no and there's no hypothesis
testing there's no statistical fitting
core anything like that so this is one
of the things which machiners do they
actually can utilize very simple
techniques to produce better results all
right so we found when we it's an
interesting thing to compare this with
linear regression if I do this with
linear regression which is more like
using this model I mean I don't get a
good fit actually this here this term
here with the epsilons they're supposed
to be identically distributed
independent identically distributed
variables you can see with this
predicted versus residual but this is
not the case we actually see some
patterns this actually means but it's a
terrible terrible fit but you know we
have done it we can actually investigate
further what is interesting here I don't
let me see this if we look at so-called
cook distances this actually they tell
us what we have outliers usually
anything larger than the threshold
threshold computing this way it's
something that has to be examined and we
can see what we do have actually fair
amount of for outliers in the data so
again this is the statistical approach
when we do the this is the major model
so to speak in statistics we do have a
model we do actually statisticians they
do use the identically independent
distributed variables as a tool fairly
often it's as important to say uniform
convergence in calculus it's used for
almost any method to be derived and when
we try to apply a methadone model they
basically describe evaluated they
actually want to see after we have
fitted everything do we get dude is this
assumption valid if it is valid then our
modern models has been valid if it is
not then we need to do something else
machine lenders don't do that but they
actually say we've just rocked
characteristics they actually can
produce some were somewhat better
results I'm out of time so I'm not going
to discuss the progressive jackpot
modeling much what I'm going to show and
maybe this is not a good idea but
basically instead of using need map for
progressive jackpot modeling we base
we have a jackpot in some slot machine
or lottery which is accumulating part of
the ticket when you buy a one dollar
ticket say ten percent is being withheld
for the jackpot the rest goes for the
organizers so that very very variety of
questions you know what kind of how much
of what tickets need to be purchased
within a month in order to the jackpot
say not to be not to be one more than
twice in a year and what is the
probability to the jackpot to be one
before it reaches kalfa million and so
forth so I mean you can use this need
map perspective with mathematica
actually can you can actually solve some
reclusive equations use binomial
distributions and so forth the thing is
what it's better to do simulations and
one of the things is but it's like a you
scare Poisson process but the thing is
that the organizers they might have some
brilliant ideas which will change your
need map quite dramatically oh it's
going to be impossible like we might say
look after somebody wins the jackpot we
don't want to start from zero because
nobody is going to play so we want to
actually also without some percent for a
withheld pot which is going to jumpstart
you know the jackpot think after after
it just one so what happens then in that
case and what happens if slot machines
they have very different performances
when they placed in different places in
the casinos so basically you might have
some kind of temporal and spatial
variants of how many people play these
machines when when and so forth with the
simulation perspective this all can be
addressed and this is discussed at
length in in in this in this notebook so
this is another I have only seven eight
minutes so again this detail to express
a detailed explanation I am NOT going to
go for it but what is happening here is
but this is a typical actually example
in which so we have some distribution
which we don't know this is X and we
know what why is some kind of noisy
distribution it's a normal distribution
we know the the variance and so after we
have
the mixture which you know like actually
favored a protein to evaluate this
because it can be more dramatic than
what is shown after you hear this
mixture it might happen what yeah well
oh this is really not good yeah well
right that's a great suggestion what I'm
going to do is to look at this here so
basically this is done mixture model so
basically I mean you can see what I mean
what I'm saying is but I can come up
with a procedure which this Gaussian
noise model I'm going to find a function
which is going to be zero on any
variable but yes Gaussian distribution
but for example kurtosis and it's going
to be nonzero to anything else and so in
this way I can formulate a optimization
of optimization on method which is going
to extract the Gaussian noise variables
this is described here this again you
know it's full detail you can actually
see you can see what is how minimize
supplied how maximized supplied and so
forth we do actually can reconstruct the
PDF in the and the CDF in this way and
it is more or less what what you expect
or at least in this particular case this
was what the user here here wanted to do
all right so I'm going to need to select
some example here very quickly with
quantile regression you basically fit
bunch of course not just one like this
is the whole point out say you can see
I'm sorry which is at the bottom too
much of the bottom here but we've linear
linear regression you can just fit a
curve which is in the middle of this of
this original signal with quantile
regression I
and fit multiple multiple curves at
different quantiles and so which I have
selected it's a very powerful method you
can reconstruct the distribution at any
given time point here you can rest
reconstruct the distribution of what is
happening you can see what some of
standard statistical assumptions but the
variance the variance is not changing in
time they don't hope for this series
actually if anything you can see what
you know like the variances is quite a
while dividing this unit lanta georgia
during the winter and it's much more
stable the signal is much more
predictable in the summer so I do
consider this to be part of form of data
mining not so much of a statistical
method because in a sense this is just
certain it's a certain optimization or
method which apply to to kind of
conditions about the points I mean you
just want some points to be above and
the law there is no there is no device
like say the gauss-markov theorem behind
this it's actually fairly data-driven
fairly fairly straightforward in a sense
to apply in a in a in not effective way
if you want to apply to an effective way
yes you need to do linear programming
formulation so forth so what is
interesting here and this is another
thing to discuss is what if i look at
the bands between if i look at the bands
made by this quantile curves like this
is my first band my second for and so i
have like seven bands i can actually see
i can actually use a sequence which
corresponds to this to this time series
basically i'm looking where the time
series is if if a point is here this is
the second band then if the next one is
here it's the first band and so forth so
i can actually form a sequence like this
and then i can apply sequence mining
algorithms so we can you can actually if
you have a collection of time series you
can if you do that you actually can also
look at the general distribution across
the collection of the different states
and apply you know information retrieval
techniques and so forth like use natural
language
sink type of techniques Markov chains in
this particular case this here gives you
conditional probabilities say from state
6 to stay in stage 6 just tells me what
the probabilities seven percent and so
forth huh this was a very interesting
example which I gave during lunch time
at the stack exchange table so I'm going
to skip it and this was also a great
example which I really don't see how we
can we can cover I do actually want to
discuss this so I already mentioned this
but so in a in statistics very often we
we do that I mean we we gather the data
transform it clean it normalize it this
is actually very important fairly often
machine London's don't do it especially
if you do crowd sourcing and this was
actually the crooks of this algorithm
here I wanted to show when use graph
based models graph-based databases you
don't need to clean your data that much
not in the way statisticians do you can
actually just connect the data as this
you know from transaction so wherever
and produce you know produce relatively
good results and in a here where several
in some other in another presentation
he'd vote from conference two three
years ago I actually did this breakdown
of problems and algorithms for machine
learning so basically if you want to if
you want to explain what machine will
let us do in some sense it's much easier
when probably with the decisions this is
kind of you know like some sort of
longhand type of right up but we do
actually in both cases you know where
certain established morals and ways to
kind of method methodologies and ways to
approach real applications so this is
the attempt here to to tool is that so
this example here from scratch
well it's very interesting but
unfortunately without pictures and so as
a summary I do actually want to do
exaggerate to this this is more like a
recapitulation example of you know if I
want to make some kind of anecdotal
memorable image of the difference
between statistics and machine learning
outside this is it you can see the first
one which is made with singular value
decomposition I'd have made a classifier
which is recognizing hundred transitions
60,000 digits 10,000 test digits you
know so forth so you can see what this
classifier has produced these basis
vectors when we use singular value
decomposition of principle component
analysis I have the middle digit which
is in the top left and then I have
differences between that so basically
we've a some neat neat kind of
theoretical justified math to do this
and yeah I'm it's a very statistical
methods you basically start with a mean
object from the set and you kind of
subtract from it and you basically will
be analyzing this error vectors and you
can see what they're actually kind of
somewhat hard to explain now in machine
learning the machine learning
perspective for this is this second
algorithm which I have applied it's
non-negative matrix factorization and
you can see what in this case the basis
all of the bases found very
interpretable so these are all different
types of 5s which have been used in the
data set so in a sense you know it's an
opportunity when I want to have an
unknown digit I need to solve an
optimization problem how I can best
represent it with this non fives and in
my opinion this is kind of a good good
recapitulation of the differences
between machine learning statistics were
fair amount of references also links
inside I strongly suggest the first link
of box on which he describes how Fisher
has been doing statistics it's very
different apparently from what
suggestions do now and the lower Bremen
picture sorry article which I used used
already mentioned stuff it's a it's very
useful to to read more about this kind
of differences Thank You attention
you